good morning John you may have noticed
several videos in a row there's this big
empty air you know why that is it's
because over here I was making a video
for wizard school and I that was my
tripod 10 years John you'd think I'd
have bought a second tripod there it is
I've better so John I think it is
important for us to talk about the
things that we disagree with our old
selves about so to talk about this train
that I used to be on called the
Machiavellian train I don't know why
it's a train and I decided just now and
the idea is that good people have to be
willing to do all the same stuff that
bad people are willing to do in order to
get a good outcome because otherwise the
bad people are gonna do all their bad
stuff and they're gonna get their bad
thing done this was a very appealing
idea to me as a younger man partly yes
because it allowed me to excuse me doing
things that maybe weren't in concert
with my values I think was mostly
because it played into this thing that I
wanted to believe about myself that if I
could only use my brain enough I could
manipulate other people in the world to
an eventual positive outcome that guy
was the protagonist in a lot of the
books that I liked like I was in 3 Wigan
or Frank Chalmers or Paul Atreides don't
know what those things are that's fine
we don't read the same kinds of books as
I have gotten more power you hear people
in social media circles call this
influence but let's call it what it is
I've gotten way more wary and even sort
of afraid of that perspective so I want
to give you some reasons why I think
that the Machiavelli train is made of BS
so first healthy societies rely on trust
and if we are all seeing each other as
pawns that trust will never exist and
when I saw people more as pawns to be
moved to my will I was able to trust
other people that's because I thought
they saw me that way too and that among
all the other bad stuff that comes with
that is just a bad feeling second you
are never a hundred percent that the
thing you're trying to accomplish is
actually gonna have a positive effect on
the world there are lots of examples of
people having big revolutions against
really oppressive things and then it
getting even worse after well there are
also examples of people having
revolutions and the outcome being good
but you never really know so if you're
headed along to this eventual goal and
you're just destroying everything on the
way there if this turns out to not
have the intended effect then you've
done a but a bad stuff to get to a bad
outcome third you got to remember that
there's a really high chance that you're
not gonna get to the desired outcome
you're never gonna get there so you
could do a whole bunch of bad stuff on
the way to trying to get there and then
fail and that happens all the time
lastly I have come to realize that this
thing doesn't exist there is no final
end goal every single decision along the
path of your life is an end in itself
and if the entire world lived as if the
ends justify the means
then the means in themselves are gonna
be a terrifying end so I jumped off that
train and now I do not see an idea as a
good idea if it requires me to define my
values or my ethics doesn't matter how
good it's gonna be in the end or what
all the stuff I could do with that money
if I got and I kind of did needed to get
okay with discarding ideas because I
couldn't figure out how to do them and
still be living the right way and that
was surprisingly hard because I think
throughout my life I praised ideas above
reality in a kind of way I don't know if
that made sense and I needed to get over
that and it's kind of been a liberation
for me because law imitations are
actually good for ideas like being able
to do anything to get to your desired
goal can be really paralyzed and to it
means that when I fail which I will do
over and over and over again and we all
will do at least along the way to that
failure I did a bunch of things that I
believed in and honestly I've come to
accept and believe that it's those
millions of tiny sometimes invisible
actions more than any huge
accomplishment that really makes
humanity work John in the last 10 years
of doing this with you and with this
community this is one of the best and
most helpful most important lessons I've
learned thank you for that
memento mori and I will see you in
Boston